the thing that brought FTX Crashing Down  is that Sam went to DC spent a lot of  money on lobbyists lobbied for this bill  that would have made uh both Bitcoin and  ethereum commodities and would have put  the cftc in control would have created  light regulation would have created a  path for other crypto tokens to be  viewed as Commodities and in addition to  like giving a lot of money to the media  a lot of money to the academics a lot of  money to the politicians and a lot of  money to the celebrities he also  inserted in the bill that that uh the  crypto exchanges would send fees to the  cftc and they in essence try to bribe  the cftc with with crypto usage fees in  order to get light regulation  that didn't go over well with a whole  set of regulators that thought that that  was a way to undermine the Securities  industry